Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
calling lawmakers back on Monday while
some are worried that they will not be
protected from the coronavirus shad
program is live in Alexandria Virginia
where Chad we have been talking about
this and there are questions from some
lawmakers themselves over whether this
is the right time
that's right Sandra there's a lot of
consternation and one of the reasons is
because the region had 2,000 new cases
on Thursday Washington DC itself had the
deadliest day yet with coronavirus 19
deaths in the District of Columbia now
Mitch McConnell he has not said whether
or not he consulted with the Capitol
attending physician or if the Capitol
attending physician gave him different
information from what was given to the
House of Representatives and when they
reconvened the Senate keep in mind this
is more than just senators that means
staff it means US Capitol police
officers also custodians this is what
worries chris van hollen Democratic
senator from Maryland I'm very worried
about all the Capitol staff and putting
their health and lives at risk and I
want to make sure that Senator McConnell
puts in place adequate protections to
make sure the Senate doesn't become a
vector for the coronavirus the House and
Senate rarely agree on much including
when each body should meet during a
pandemic the house originally planned to
meet next week to the Democratic leaders
retreated when the Capitol attending
physician dr. Brian Monahan expressed
concerns about the house returning as
numbers in Washington DC aren't dropping
yet and it's a little surprise that in
Congress returning to session is a
Democrat versus Republican issue
gotten guidance from the attending
physician and I'm a physician and I
agree with what we're going to be doing
starting Monday in the Senate in a safe
and smart way
now on Monday they will have one
confirmation vote it's a low level
nomination also hearings this week one
on the crisis facing the airlines also a
hearing on Thursday about testing and a
confirmation next week on confirming
John Ratcliffe the congressman
Republican representative from Kentucky
excuse me from Texas to be the Director
of National Intelligence